سننطلق هذه المره من الجنوب وتحديدا فعلا
من خان يونس كنا تابعنا التطورات اللافته
تابعنا ما اعلنته كتائب القسام الفيديو
الذي اظهر عمليات الاستهداف لاليات عسكريه
في اكثر من محور نحن نتحدث بالاساس عن هذه
الجبهه الغربيه وايضا الجنوبيه الغربيه من
خان يونس كان هناك حديث وايضا اخبار عن
عمليه قصف اسرائيلي ل عدد من المواقع سواء
في وسط خان يونس ولكن ايضا في غربها وفي
جنوبها وتحديدا لو ذهبنا الى تفاصيل
الخريطه يمكن الاشاره الى مجموعه من
المحاور نحن نتحدث بالاساس عن عمليات
استهداف لمنطقه الامل وايضا اشتباكات هنا
في المناطق الغربيه في وقت تحدثت فيه
المقاومه سواء كتائب القسام او سرايا
القدس عن عمليه استهداف لاليات عسكريه
دبابات من نوع كافا وذلك بقذائف الياسين
ولكن ايضا باستهداف ايضا تحصينات ل جنود
تحصنوا في احد المنازل واستهدافها بقذائف
مضاده للتحصينات اذا هذه الجبهه خصوصا هنا
في منطقه الامل هي موضع الاشتباكات لكن
الجديد هو ايضا هو استراتيجيه نسف مربعات
سكنيه باكملها كما حدث هنا في جوره العقاد
ولكن ايضا حديث الهلال الاحمر ال فلسطيني
ايضا عن عمليه استهداف وقصف بجوار مستشفى
الامل وايضا بجوار مستشفى ناصر في محاوله
لدفع النازحين وهم بالالاف في هذه المناطق
الى النزوح لا ندري الى اين هل الى
المناطق الشماليه ام الى رفح
وبالاشكال فه في هذه المنطقه بالذهاب الى
رفح يمكن الاشاره الى ما
ذكره وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
حول رفح حينما قال مع العلم بان رفح
والمنطقه الفاصله بينها وبين خانيونس
تعرضت الى احزمه ناريه تبعها امس واول امس
تحدث على انه سنتمكن من الوصول الى رفح
متى وكيف لم يذكر ذلك اذا جبهه رفح هي
جبهه محتمله مع هذه الاحزمه الناريه خصوصا
في المناطق الشرقيه لو سريعا ذهبنا الى
المنطقه الوسطى ربما اللافت هو هذه
الاستهدافات هنا في المناطق الشرقيه من
المنطقه الوسطى من خلال استهداف المقاومه
في منطقه شرق المصدر وايضا في شرق المغازي
لاليات عسكريه وتجمعات لجنود الاحتلال لكن
ايضا كان هناك عمليه قصف للبيج ودير البلح
اكثر من 30 شهيدا خلال اليومين فقط في
منطقه دير البلح ربما نختم بالحديث عن
المنطقه الشماليه في هذه المنطقه الشماليه
كان لافتا هذا القصف المكثف للمناطق خصوصا
المناطق الجنوبيه من مدينه غزه كان هناك
استهداف بالاساس لمناطق جنوبي جحر الديك
ولكن ايضا في مناطق تل الهواء وايضا في
منطقه ايضا الامل لكن الملحوظ هو انه هذه
المناطق مناطق تل الهواء وايضا المناطق
حينما نذهب اليها بالتفصيل مناطق الرمال
وايضا مناطق الصبره هذه المناطق تشهد ايضا
اشتباكات عنيفه تخوضها المقاومه هنا مع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تحاول ايضا
التوغل الى هذه المناطق للمره الثالثه بعد
ان كانت قد انسحبت منها في سابق الاقوات
اذا تطورات لافته في الشمال لكن جبهه خان
يونس ربما هي الابرز وسيله تحتاج الى
تحليل مع اللواء الدويري